Speaker 1: All right.
When I make a mistake on the show and it's
more than just, you know, I just some kind
of minor thing, I want to make sure I come
to you and I say Sirs and M&Ms.
I made a mistake and I want to.
I want to correct the record.
On Monday, I talked about the Glasgow Climate
Change Summit and the outrage over 400 private
jets flying there.
And the irony and hypocrisy of Let's fix climate
and let's talk about it by flying in on our
private jets, which on a per person basis,
the carbon expenditures are off the charts.
And I said a lot of different things in that
segment, including that rich people are going
to keep using private jets and that the economics
of private jets just make sense for CEOs and
other dignitaries when you account all different
factors.
Eventually, private jets can run on renewable
fuels and they're not going away, and that
the real problem is that this is a distraction
sort of like change your straw and recycle
at home.
I said, this is a distraction from the fact
that 100 companies are responsible for 71
percent of all emissions.
That was not accurate, and I actually got
an email from Samuel about this.
The article that I put up on the screen is
a Guardian article from four years ago.
It's been widely shared, and it says 100 companies
are responsible for 71 percent of global emissions.
A small number of fossil fuel producers and
their investors could hold the key to tackling
climate change.
This this is not representative of the truth.
OK.
This has actually been looked at.
I'm glad to be corrected.
You can check out the Snopes article about
it.
It's misleading in the following sense.
What the actual data is is that within the
universe of fossil fuel producers, 71 percent
of the pollution from fossil fuel producers
comes from just 100 companies.
It doesn't account for all sorts of other
types of companies that also pollute.
So when I said 100 companies are responsible
for 71 percent of pollution, that's within
fossil fuel producers, coal gas drilling,
etc., it doesn't account for everything.
The analysis is still the same.
The analysis is still there are corporations
that pollute either directly by mining fossil
fuels or indirectly through their business
models that would leave it for the attention
to be on.
Did you recycle every milk carton or not?
Are you still using a plastic straw rather
than the significant industrial pollution
that they contribute to?
So the analysis is the same, but that statistic
100 companies contribute to 71 percent of
all pollution.
No, it's within fossil fuels within the fossil
fuel industry.
Seventy one percent of that pollution comes
from 100 fossil fuel producers.
I'm sorry the analysis is the same, but it
would have been stronger had I not cited that.
And I'm going to do better in the future.